le sport la santé et les jeunes au cœur
d'un forum organisé par le service
jeunesse d'élancour suite à une enquête
qu'elle a mené la ville a voulu informer
et pousser les jeunes à pratiquer une
activité sportive je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'accidents au travers du sport et que
certaines certaines populations certains
certains jeunes restai malgré tous les
clubs présents sur la ville encore un
petit peu en retrait et du coup ne
pratique pas de sport bouger oui mais il
faut savoir bien le faire et pour donner
les bons conseils tout un panel de
professionnels de santé était au
rendez-vous une des premières règles
pour un sportif savoir gérer son
alimentation j'essaye c'est pas facile
parce que bah quand on est jeune on sort
beaucoup aussi
et c'est pas facile je leur dit que
c'est vraiment important de bien
s'hydrater tout au long de l'année de
bien manger tout au long de l'année mais
surtout la semaine précédente parce que
là je ris s'ils ont bien mangé la veille
c'est sûr que ça va être mieux mais si
par exemple toute la semaine ils ont
fait plein des écart et ils ont pas
beaucoup bu ils sont pas bien hydratés
ils vont avoir quand même des séquelles
donc c'est pourtant en des conséquences
en tout cas des des contreperformances
ou autrees contre performance RIM alor
avec mauvaise alimentation mais pas
seulement sur le forum une psychologue a
également alerté sur les addictions qui
ne font jamais bon ménage avec la
pratique
sportive plus le tabac plus le tabac
mais bon il y a aussi l'alcool l'alcool
est souvent une une addiction pour
laquelle on a plus de mal à parler donc
le tabac c'est quand même socialement
quelque chose qui est anumis donc on
vient souvent nous voir pour arrêter de
fumer et puis dans l'entretien on se
rend compte au bout d'un certain temps
où le patient nous dit hein
effectivement qu'il y a aussi un
problème
d'alcool lors de ce forum parmi la
vingtaine d'exposants 10 associations
sportives et l'an courourtois en ont
aussi profité pour faire découvrir leur
discipline